je suis aussi fait partie de la troupe
bonne là c'est la bande blanche juste à
côté
quand vous avez montauban participe au
très attendu l'été nous avons un rameur
qui nous a fait faux bond si je peux me
permettre l'expression pour une fois on
aurait pu faire quelque chose ensemble
et pour vannes a dit non pour que tu as
refusé par guignols à la télé j'ai pas
besoin de ça pour être regardés de
travers
merci maman déconne je vous comprends
pas du cul
je suis seul j'avais envie de tendre le
petit nouveau christian facture on
souhaite la bienvenue
bienvenue kristian dahl étaient à gagner
moi j'y crois la marque tu ai demandé de
me suivre au commissariat on est venu
chercher l'arabe à la sortie du
commissariat
parait-il type lorient
vous racontez ça dégueulasse que tu as
fait
je me trompe et combien comme ça toi
cherche à compenser
tapie ta place dans l'équipe et s'il ya
que des gens honnêtes et sportif
soit tombé
tu as cassé tu dois réparer
[Musique]
e